I started playing Harry Potter magic
awakened when it released here in the US
on June 27 2023 and on July 14th I hit
the rank of Grand Master
oh my gosh it was so close Grand Master
free to play Grand Master ladies and
gentlemen so Juan's at the ready witches
and wizards I'm going to give you the 10
steps I followed to reach Grandmaster
and how these tips can help you on your
PVP journey in Harry Potter magic
awakened now we're going to start off
basic and move to the more advanced as
we go throughout the list here so step
one is going to be learn the cards
understanding the strengths and
weaknesses of each card in your deck is
absolutely crucial take some time to
study the card abilities and strategize
how to best utilize them in battle each
card has a detailed description and
stats that explain its purpose there's
even a little video you can watch in the
description to see what it looks like in
gameplay but honestly while it does help
to read the descriptions the best
teacher in this case is to learn by
doing by simply playing the game you're
going to learn so much about the
advantages and disadvantages of each
card you can learn a lot just doing PVE
activities like the Forbidden Forest but
you'll want to spend a lot of time in
the PVP mode to get a better
understanding of how real opponents will
respond to your attacks switch to
practice mode if you aren't comfortable
jumping into the rank mode right away
there's also a dueling tutorial that's
very short but contains a lot of helpful
information such as the fact fact that
you can quickly cast spells by double
tapping on them it's important to learn
which spells are best cast with a double
tap and which ones you need to aim
manually by tapping and dragging once
you have a good understanding of the
cards you're ready to move to step two
experiment with different Echoes the
echo you choose really defines the type
of playstyle you should have and the
types of cards you need in your deck new
and Hagrid players for example should
rely heavily on magical creatures
whereas Hermione players need a balance
of low-cost spells and one or two high
cost spells for Snape users Time Turner
is an absolute must and then there's the
echo that carried me to Grand Master
Bellatrix Lestrange with this Echo you
want to deal a lot of damage to build up
the meter for her Death Eater I even saw
a few Weasley twin Decks that were
really strong on my road to Grand Master
but like step one the best knowledge
here will again be through gaining your
own experience by playing and trying out
the Echoes you'll want to pick the one
that best suits your play style but also
one that pairs well with the cards you
like using the most you'll also want to
learn subtle nuances to your Echo like
positioning of bellatrix's Death Eaters
for example or how you want to play a
more up close aggressive style of play
if you're running the Snape Echo and
speaking of where you're actually set up
on the board that's where step three
comes in positioning and patience as far
as the actual gameplay within each duel
positioning and Patience are vital to
success early on you may be tempted to
move around frequently and spam spells
the moment they become ready in your
hand and while this can work in the
early Tears like bronze silver and even
gold once you hit Platinum rank you'll
need to make sure you learn the Nuance
of good positioning and also that you're
patient with the cards in your hand when
it comes to positioning make sure you
don't linger too close to your summons
or companions if your opponent wants to
burn an incendio to take out something
like a niffler at least make sure you
aren't standing so close that you take
damage as well generally you also want
to avoid going up too close to your
opponent staying back further gives you
more time to react to summons and makes
you harder to hit on long range spells
now of course if you're playing Snape
then you definitely want to play more up
close those first three steps though
should really help you move up through
the early ranks like bronze silver and
gold to make the jump to platinum and
eventually Diamond you'll need to
implement more advanced steps from here
on out you may notice that some of the
strategies you use to get here will stop
working or get countered more easily and
that's why it's important to take step 4
into account look for patterns in your
losses start paying closer attention to
the stats after matches where you lose
and even where you win there's a lot of
information available at the end of each
battle right at your fingertips if you
just take the time to look you can even
watch a full replay of your recent games
look at the spells your opponent used
most often and see which ones did the
most damage to you was it one particular
spell you had trouble with or a lot of
heavy summons are they using an echo
that your style of play has trouble
dealing with if you start to notice a
lot of the same patterns then it may be
time to adjust your deck this is exactly
what I had to do when I reached the
diamond rank the deck you see here is
what I had used most up to this point
but then I started having a lot of
trouble with two spells in particular
orb of water and thunderstorm so I
switched to this deck right here I added
expulso to help me break free from
opponent's casting orb of water as well
as nebulous to help me hide from
thunderstorm we also haven't talked too
much about companions yet I ended up
going with Cassandra for spam control
Hermione and Slot 2 for the double
thunderstorm and Hagrid and the final
slot for extra defense and mobility in
the end game Ivy is also a really good
one to have in your lineup as she can
instantly take out other companions or
powerful summons now you may also notice
that I removed atmospheric charm and
this relates directly to step 5. pay
attention to the banned cards once you
hit the Platinum rank you'll get to
participate in a vote to ban two cards
each week and in this week for my region
it just so happened to be pure totem
locomotor and the Norwegian Ridgeback
egg while I think atmospheric charm is a
really strong spell its primary purpose
in my deck was to counter the Norwegian
Ridgeback I definitely prefer to have
the cats in my lineup instead of
atmospheric charm if given the choice so
don't be afraid to swap out cards in
your deck to match with the bands each
week even if you don't use one of the
cards that got banned yourself if
there's a card in your deck that just
isn't as useful based on the current
banned cards then definitely take it out
for something that would serve you
better with the current active cards now
when I hit Diamond I started
consistently running into players with
more HP than me higher Spellbook levels
than me and higher card levels than me
so that takes us to step six level up
look while this guide is mostly geared
toward free to play players even as free
to play you can do things to optimize
your leveling up first make sure you're
in a social club so you can trade cards
if you're still looking join up in our
Discord Link in the video description
below and we can get you into one of our
clubs this was absolutely huge for me as
I had a very active social club and was
able to get a lot of the cards I was
using in my deck I focused heavily on
the cards that I was using most in my
Bellatrix deck and then used the cards I
traded for to start leveling them up
this in turn increased my overall
Spellbook level but I wasn't just
upgrading anything I really made sure to
focus on those cards that I used in my
deck also make sure you pay attention to
the Daily shop and don't be afraid to
spend gems on the cards that you use the
most I do not recommend spending the 20
or 30k coins on the legendary though
you're definitely going to need those
coins to upgrade your cards instead
especially as your cards get higher and
higher in addition to upgrading your
cards and companions you should also
look to step 7 secure a legendary Echo
you'll get your first legendary Echo by
completing the haunted hollow level 8 or
the solo forest level 25. I think the
haunted hollow is much easier to
complete even if you're a bit below the
recommended level and that's actually
how I landed my first Bellatrix
legendary Echo now unfortunately I know
not everyone is going to get their ideal
echo on their first try and there's even
less of a chance that it will actually
have good cards but I can't stress
enough how getting this legendary Echo
and then having a few boosted cards from
it in my deck helped out a ton if you're
still with me by this point chances are
you're pretty serious about trying to
hit Grand Master you probably put a lot
of time in and trust me I know it can
get really frustrating at times and this
is why I think step 8 is so important
walk away during losing streaks I was
actually over 6300 at one point and then
fell down almost 500 points when I had a
really bad day but please don't make the
same mistake that I did I would
recommend setting a losing streak limit
for yourself maybe around I don't know
three losses in a row if you lose three
in a row get it from the game go for a
walk drink some water just anything you
can do to get away from the game for a
while trust me you'll come back feeling
refreshed and more focused than you were
before now if you want a little extra
peace of mind that's where step nine
comes in through drafts of Peace don't
forget about these potions they will
help protect you for the next one to
three games based on the size of the
potion I actually completely forgot
about these until I was very close to my
Grandmaster I would recommend using a
large draft a piece when you're about
100 points off of your next Milestone I
used one right around 7 400 so I knew
that no matter what I wouldn't lose any
points for the next three matches what's
funny is I actually ended up playing
better and more relaxed with this potion
active I won all three of those games
anyway but I'm still glad the potion was
there as for the small drafts I
personally like to use those to stop a
losing streak let's say you lose three
in a row but you really want to give it
one more shot to try and turn things
around use a small draft a piece at the
very least you won't lose any more
points with the next loss if you win you
can keep playing to see if you can turn
it around but if you lose then you know
it may be time for a longer break now
for step 10 and this is really the one
that helped push me over the top watch
high level gameplay of other players I
picked up so many things doing this and
it really helped me to see what I was
doing wrong and also learn a few new
strategies along the way I actually have
a full breakdown of my final three
matches to reach Grand Master right here
on YouTube that video is over on the
right side of your screen next
definitely check that one out as always
guys thank you all so much for watching
I'll talk to you again soon